[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us today
we look at the healing power of
friendship 21 years ago a group of women
in Maryland rallied around their friend
Harriet as she battled the debilitating
effects of multiple sclerosis chip read
shows us how the group with the chickee
name of Harriet's harem is still keeping
her strong a comforting massage the book
club loved it a manicure just a walk
down memory lane
you said kill her with kindness this is
what Harriet's harem is all about 21
years ago
Harriet Friedkin's friends created a
caregiving group when multiple sclerosis
stole Harriet's physical freedom every
Monday through Friday
Harriet gets a visitor but when the
group heard that we were coming they all
came at the same time to tell us about
their extraordinary friend why do you do
this
helps her it helps me and it's it's I
think it's just good for me it's just a
joy for me to be able to be with her my
inspiration
Karen Bala Macy is one of the founding
members is this an example of that old
saying it's better to give than to
receive absolutely we both give and
receive at the same time so to me it's a
win-win situation
Barbara ran hand is a relatively junior
member joining just 11 years ago
she plays sudo COO with Harriet and
organizes the monthly calendar what is
it about Harriet that makes everybody
want to take care of her
it's Harriet I think she stimulates all
of us and I love really talking to her
but I love listening to her Harriet has
been very helpful to me in my personal
life and whatever I can get back as I
tell her quote-unquote Harriet you saved
my life now you're stuck with me forever
that is a consistent theme with this
group but Harriet says she has the
better end of the deal
what do you appreciate most patient
communication the talking oh yeah is
there some gossip that goes on wait
Harriet's husband Jerry says the harem
gives her a level of support that he
can't do you believe that her health is
better today than it would be if she did
not have Harriet Sarah absolute her
mental health their mental health
absolutely really I think her worst
times are the weekend why not there's no
harem here at all she thrives on the
harem Harriet's daughters agree the
benefits that we see in mom if other
people could use this and also be able
to duplicate it she doesn't think of
herself as sick she just thinks that she
can't move yeah that's the attitude that
really helps that right inconvenience
it's an inconvenience yeah her family
and her harem say that positive outlook
on life is Harriet's gift to them I want
people getting out of this to see how
wonderful my wife is as simple as that
you're lucky man I am this is a happy
story and I want people to understand
this is a happy story for CBS this
morning
chip Reid Potomac Maryland I love that
story so much that's how I take it to
guys is a happiness story it just shows
you the power of friendships what it can
do for you yeah and you see it all in
Harriet's eyes that's right you're gonna
light up the room with those so win-win
for everybody